[Music]
do you have questions about your
medicare eligibility rocky is live
inside the call late phone bank where
alignment health plan is ready to help
hey rocky hey yes they are ready to help
we've been hanging out in here the
phones have been ringing so give them a
call at that number
702-650-1101 and they are here to help
you and answer any questions because
healthcare and health plans medicare
it's all a little complicated right rick
yeah it's very very complicated and this
is that time to really ask those
questions and not be afraid to call in
these folks here they don't charge
anything they're here just to help you
know that's why we do these things so
that they can get those questions
answered and they can then feel good
about what they're doing is such an
important time of year for them because
things change from year to year thank
goodness that they have this time that
they can call maybe it's a different
doctor or their medicines are different
and these folks here that's what they do
all day long they help them understand
is this really still the right plan for
you or is this plan better for you and
help them with their co-pays their
out-of-pocket costs there's just a lot
they can do with that absolutely and
that's why if you already are on
medicare it's good to call in and just
get a review of your plan right because
this is really important to your health
and your well-being so how do these
plans affect your health and what do
they need to know yeah it's very
important for them to understand that i
think sometimes they look at these plans
like it's what happens if something goes
wrong you know do i have hospital
coverage do i have doctor coverage well
that's all true but what about a plan
like alignment health plan that wants to
know how do we keep you healthier right
you know can we give you a gym
membership can we give you a ride to
pick up your prescription can we make
sure that your mri or cat scan has no
co-pay which is what alignment has in
their plans so you don't you're not
afraid to get that test you need for us
it's really more about keeping you
healthy not taking care of you after you
get sick and that's what's so important
right now is make sure you're getting
the plan that will do that the best for
you that is a great point rick and the
next question is you know why is this
medicare enrollment period so important
why shouldn't you miss that again you
know we're back to that time of year
where they can just you know ask
questions and make sure that they're you
know thankfully we have this because if
things did change for them right this is
the time of year to really they can look
at it and make that change because we
know a year is a long time and
especially with all that's been going on
in our crazy world with covet and
everything things change so maybe it's
the right time and the right you know
for them to just check it out and make
sure everything's still good okay and i
hear the phones are ringing so our call
bank uh answers are working hard to
answer questions for you you know not
let's end it by just introducing a lyman
health plan to the community you guys
have been here for a year officially yep
a full year officially now we're super
excited we're very engaged with the
community we all live here i live here
too so we're here to be a participant an
active provider in this community we
work with great health plan partners
like p3 health partners so we're here to
stay and we just keep improving and
getting better well thank you so much
rick and thank you to our answers to our
phone answers here if you guys are
interested in getting your medicare
questions answered give us a call at
702-650-1101
today till 7 pm and this is alignment
health plan giving you all the
information you need to stay well out
here right rick that's right we want
them to stay well of course so i will
send it back to you and we'll check in
in the later shows today thank you so
much rocky the call late phone bank is
happening until 7 pm today the number
again is 702-650-1101
las vegas now we'll be right back